- (Kelly) Speaking of cooking,
is it true that you actually
cooked with Meryl Streep
in her apartment while
making Julia & Julia?
- We did.
We, we cooked together when
we're about to start the film.
I asked her if we could cook together,
we had both finished shooting films prior,
and I knew she was busy and tired,
but I said not to be too method-ie,
but could we just cook together?
And we did. And we had a great time.
We cooked one of Julia's recipes.
We cooked the Blanquette de Veau,
which is a sort of creamy veal dish.
And it ended up being delicious.
However, it was, we were too slow
and we thought we're going
to serve dinner at eight,
we served it at a 10.
(Laughter)
- This is my problem with cooking. Okay.
I can actually cook, but it
takes me like three hours
to do what it takes someone
like 30 minutes to 45 minutes.
I'm so slow.
Cause I get nervous and I
triple check everything,
but that's, like, quite a
recipe to like, be like,
let's our first time cooking together.
You just jumped right into
like a really hard recipe.
That's amazing.
- (Stanley Tucci) Yeah we did.
And she, she had made a tarte tatin
based on a Julia's recipe,
that was actually delicious.